[Music]
now is dave rubin host of the rubin
report and author the fantastic new book
don't burn this book all right Dave you
know Silicon Valley better than most
people why is musk just a voice crying
in the wilderness here given what's
happening in the rest of the country
well he's an innovator he's an inventor
he's someone that loves the free market
and loves capitalism and loves freedom
and you know we need our innovators to
be interesting and think outside of the
box and he's here obviously in
California that's where I am I'm in Los
Angeles not in Silicon Valley but we're
run we're a state run by progressives
big government progressives who think
they apparently know everything I mean
our governor Gavin Newsom I mean he was
the mayor of San Francisco and in effect
he ruined San Francisco to the point
that Peter Thiel Alon Musk's former
partner in PayPal had to leave San
Francisco and moved to Los Angeles
because he want he wanted some free
thinking I mean imagine moving to Los
Angeles for free thinking but that's
what Peter Thiel is doing I mean that
really tells you what happened in San
Francisco and now we've sort of sent
that across the state I mean we've got a
governor of Mayer here in Los Angeles
Eric Garcetti who's telling me I should
be spying and snitching on my neighbors
and now we've got gavin newsom saying
we're shutting down the the beaches it's
like if i can't go to the beaches in
california in SoCal where today it was
about 82 and beautiful all day long it's
like what am I doing here why am i pay
why am i paying these taxes I mean I got
Texas Ted Cruz I mean you know can you
give me a welcome package or something
I'm on my way man yeah David I mean
they're shutting down Rehoboth Beach
their 4th of July celebrations the
Democrat mayor Coons they're here at 4th
of July it's two months away they're
already canceling all of that I mean so
the summer is canceled in blue state
America it's canceled no summer no fun
no it's it's over I mean it because they
can predict the future Dave well Laura
you know the simple thing here that
we're all struggling to accept is that
when we reopen and the states will have
to do it state-by-state that is actually
what the Khans
Lucian would say that's what federalism
is right governors should figure out
what's best for their state and of
course what's best for New York which
has a serious problem because of the
metropolitan area and people living on
top of each other is going to be very
different than what's good for Montana
or Colorado or something else but what
we're seeing here is that the
progressive states they want to exercise
power over us I mean it really is
getting that simple what we have to
grapple with is that when we reopen
there are going to be some consequences
perhaps there will be some sort of
second wave
perhaps some older people will catch
Cova die mean all of these things that
if you say it I mean Ben Shapiro who I
know is a friend of yours as well he was
on my show yesterday and basically
that's what he said that we're gonna
have to weigh some tough choices because
we can't live in our houses forever and
we can't tank the economy and then of
course Media Matters and the and the
rest of the crew if he wants to kill
yeah well that's the game yeah come on
this this is what actuaries do it's
called risk versus reward risk versus
freedom and what I can tell from all of
the people that I'm talking to it's not
that people just want to get out there
and do whatever they want with no rules
and suddenly be a concert stadium and
build up and no mess people they want to
be smart they want to be responsible and
on top of everything else you know we're
also seeing these authoritarian
governors like Whitmer in Michigan who
you've talked about I mean the woman
she's telling people they can't plant
seeds I literally mailed seeds to fans
of mine in Michigan and I hope that
makes me a federal convict authorities
we are calling the authorities yeah this
is seed fraud all right dance let's
bring in a roll babe orders all right we
gotta roll my friend what we're seeing
all right congrats on the vote thank you
so much if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell